you say the writing process is about
tools and skills
not theory but let's let's go with
theory for one moment so
what theories are stopping a writer
before they even start
that's actually a really good question
because
um i believe that the theories
are tools i believe that the the all the
rules i'm not saying there are no rules
there are
plenty of rules there are a lot of rules
what there are not is a single set of
rules that always works
and so what you need to do is know every
possible theory you can cram into your
head
you should watch all sorts of different
types of stories
you should watch outside in genres
outside of the ones you like you should
specifically try to watch things
that are things you don't think you'd be
interested in
and you should definitely try to read
those screenwriting books or or listen
to
screenwriting teachers who are teaching
very very different ideas because there
are so many out there now
and the answer is each one of them will
have very
valuable parts very valuable
tools that you can use and the only
thing that you need to have is a really
big toolbox as big as you can get
with every possible theory so that when
you're approaching
your work which is really what it's
always going to be about
you can say i have seen a story like
this
or i have seen a story like this but
this other story
had a different form for it or this
person
said i should always have my transitions
in
the middle of the story or this one said
i should always have a conflict at the
end of the story there's so many
theories
none of them is wrong they're all right
they're
all there to be used in different
circumstances depending on what you're
trying to accomplish
so the more that you can learn all the
different
theories and all the different paradigms
and and story archetypes
that's all good but nothing will help
until you actually sit down and say i am
making the choice to write
this particular story and this story
needs
this set of rules maybe another story
needs another set
maybe i need to pick one rule from this
one and one rule from that one maybe
my you know somebody says you know save
the cat
i happen to believe that there are
certain parts of save the cat the book
very valuable other parts i can't make
head or tail of
and i don't think that you should not
read it i think you should read it
and take the pieces that you need i'm
not sure you should always save the cat
but it's good to know that saving the
cat is a thing you can do
and i believe that that goes for every
screenwriting theory out there and the
best thing that you can do
is know all of them so that you can say
in this one is this type of character
best
revealed by saving a cat or
is this one somebody who's going to walk
away and leave the cat there and now we
know a different thing about them
how do we still like them
so really the most important thing is to
take whatever these rules are
and apply them to your
particular goals because that's the
thing
not every story has the same goals some
are trying to amuse you some are trying
to scare you some are trying to make you
think
they're going to have very different
ways of approaching storytelling
the important thing is that you have as
many tools
as you can as many skills you know how
to make something funny if you need to
or how to make somebody like a character
by the way
my theory on liking a character is the
way that we like a character is that we
know
what they want i believe we can really
get with
a character who wants something horrible
they're not saving any cats they're
murderers or they're trying to take over
the world and we can still
really care about them because we are
understand that they want this thing for
their reason
and very often that's something that we
can care about even though
we don't honestly want them to kill all
those people
but we get engaged in the story and we
follow the characters because we know
what they want my theory
so if we don't know what they what they
want then somehow
do we not trust the character i
personally think we just don't think of
them as a character
i i think if you if you start to pay
attention to how you watch characters
i think you'll find out that you're
always thinking what do they want what
are they trying to do
there'll be some form of that you don't
just want to watch someone say oh they
have nice clothes i mean you'll watch
that for a few minutes
but after a while that person in the
cool outfit
had better be trying to do something
and people don't try to do something if
they don't want something
because it takes effort to do stuff and
we only do that when we have something
we want
if we have that toolbox let's let's say
we put aside the save the cat
tool what's one of the most overused
whether it's
good or bad tool one or two from this
toolbox um
we're going to pull it out and make room
for other stuff yeah
um
i think the three-act structure
it's tricky there are there is a a world
where there's units of entertainment
which you watch in one dose call them
features now
doesn't matter it could be a short but
but there's a type of story that you
watch
in one dose and that does have a
three-act structure in the sense that it
has a beginning middle and end
but the whole set of rules about turning
points happening at a certain point
in a three-act structure is
simply an overused tool it
came about because movies were in movie
theaters and that was about as long as a
person could sit in a movie theater
and also movie theaters wanted to sell a
certain number of tickets
so they wanted movies to be of a certain
length a lot of this comes down to
business
and honestly we shouldn't be making our
artistic decisions based on the fact
that
movie theaters want to turn over the
seats every 90 minutes
now we have some stories that are not
three acts
we have some stories that are 30 acts we
have some stories that are one act
every story though will have a beginning
middle and end
so in a way the three act structure will
apply even an episode of a larger thing
has a beginning middle and end um i
think that's where the
three act thing came from because
truthfully even in theater they didn't
always have three acts a lot of plays
before the 19th the 20th century had
four acts or five acts so three act
save the cat possibly doesn't mean
they're bad or wrong but it's just
they're over
they they're used a lot i'm saying
that you need to choose your form
you need to say i am going to watch a
thousand stories and i'm going to break
some down i
strongly suggest that if there's
something you like watch it like
five times watch it until you're not
enjoying it anymore so you can start to
watch it mechanically
and say how do they do this and when you
do that
stop like pause and write an outline
of the thing you're watching that you
like and learn how it's structured
and then do that with a bunch of other
things because you'll find out there's
nothing consistent the rules are all
over the place
and furthermore a lot of these rules are
like
well you have your inciting incident or
your
you know beginning twist or whatever
they everybody has names for them
none of that really matters because then
you get into
an activity which is an academic
activity of a
find the part i'm going to name the
inciting incident
what really matters is how the audience
feels as they're following the story
the audience is not looking for an
inciting incident they're not looking
for
a second act reversal they don't care
they care about the characters and if
you break down
the things you love and reverse engineer
them and outline them
you'll begin to get a sense of how they
do it
how many beats does it take before you
are worn out of this thing how
long does it go before there's a twist
or a turn
the only way you can really become
skilled
is by breaking down the work and doing
it yourself
you know you can study how to build a
car
until the end of time but you need to
actually put together a car and make it
run
and you probably have to do that a bunch
of times before you can make a really
great car
you